what does it feel like
to be a uh or what does it take to be a
woman
ceo of a meat company i mean you're no
longer ceo of bill campbell but you did
you ran
you co-founded belcampo you ran it for
many many years
is there something that you could say uh
in terms of challenges associated with
that
and how did you personally overcome it
so to be a female running a
me and livestock operation i felt very
alone
a lot you know for a long time i felt
very
uh like everybody waiting for me
to fail or watching and
assuming that i was like just good at
marketing or whatever else and
and um so it it's taken me
a while to
not internalize that
i think the only reason i've i'm here
is we have our own supply chain in
slaughterhouse and i think had i
really been playing in the broader meet
industry it would have been a shorter
journey you know it would have been very
hard to make it
even get to this phase um
but i do you know i think
the mission is my life's work
the mission of cleaner ingredients that
taste so amazing you don't need to
do too much to them you know i i like
creating food that's
in support of good health yeah and then
secondary to that
it's the environment but like i want
healthy food to be a joy to eat
right and um
that that's you know creating
innovation in the space for this company
has been about building
a brand that people understand and is
transparent and
that people believe in in an industry
that's broadly perceived as pretty
corrupt
so those are things i feel enormously
proud of um so you focused on the
mission and the com
the the pushback all the mess
the of the industry you try not to
internalize it try not to let it affect
you and focus on the mission you know
and it's in the joy of it and the part
where it's gotten
fun for me has been returning to what i
love about it
and i've only had the privilege of doing
that pretty recently
um so i think for me personally you know
starting
i hosted these events on the farm called
meat camps where i cook and teach people
to cook and and you know taste and talk
about flavor and all the like sensual
aspects of it that i that are my fire
like
thank goodness i did that stuff because
otherwise it was just such a beating
you know so there were parts of it where
i got to feed my fire
and then now in the you know the past
year since resigning i've been i do all
the recipe development i shoot all the
content
i you know taste product i'm developing
all of our new products i launched our
meatballs i'm just about to launch our
chicken meatballs
doing a high protein bone broth like
those are that's what
why i did this was to be able to build
this great product that i could build on
so i'm kind of at that place now um but
it's taken a lot longer and i think you
know looking at
the landscape of what to do in food this
is definitely
we tackled the most complicated problem
well i can imagine you know and did it
look like in the most old-fashioned way
yeah right so it's been
super complex and then i also look at
and i'm like yeah and it's been messy
and it's gonna continue to be hard
but i'm proud of having tackled the
heart problems
so so the hard problem here is not in
the space of technologies
it's in the space of bringing uh
something that we've done
for a long long time in our human
history
and uh scaling it
in the face of all the other economic
pressures
like doing so successfully also
communicating to the rest of the world
that this is
a powerful solution so inspiring the
rest of the world that regenerative
farming
like running a company in this kind of
way that's humane for animals
good for the land good for people even
if it costs like if there's an increased
cost to the meat
uh even if that if you have a broader
vision that means eating less meat
overall that that is that is like
inspiring the world that this is a
future we want
and just taking that on and getting that
done
you